i'm not frightened of course i'm
frightened as everybody but i have so
many people i'm responsible for i'm
responsible for my family i'm
responsible for my business so i contact
my colleagues every single day we have
many chats to talk and to support each
other and all these people need
psychological help all these people need
some salaries yeah to buy food
so
i'm a little bit frustrated but to tell
the truth i i thought i would be even
more frightened but now i feel like a
soldier i feel that i have a lot of
energy to just to fight because i know
that we will win i know that this war
against putin is uh
is war he couldn't win
fighting for
democracy because
democracy is precious
and one man can decide that another
country shouldn't have it
i was over in iraq and
yeah it was there for a few months and
then uh
flew home
saw my missing kids hadn't seen him for
a while and uh basically said yeah
i'm going to ukraine so uh big shop
and uh i feel a bit a little bit sorry
for them to be fair and i was pretty
upset but um
you know
people need me here get out of the train
station go to safe zone like red cross
areas and square next to it and then
i'll go there and volunteer
thank you first aid
no i'm good
i'm good with my
where are you from